так усіх цікавий теми що там по
Каховський ГЕС що по Херсонщині взагалі
значить ситуацію наступна близько
третьої ночі противник діс- здійснив
підрив каховської ГЕС для того щоб
піднявся рівень води для того щоб
затопити підступи і безпосередньо лівий
берег Дніпра а також в населені пункти
які там є і вони можливо те майбутнє
просування збройних сил України в
результаті так як лівий берег нижчий ніж
правий берег Херсона Він більш
підтоплений і позиції противника які
знаходились на самому березі Дніпра
також затопило потрібно розуміти що
позиції противника - це не тільки
траншеї а й звичайні будинки цивільних в
яких вони сиділи і цимізм полягає навіть
не тільки у тому що росіянин абсолютно
все рівно на цивільне населення на
інфраструктуру на те що Це техногенна
катастрофа для того щоб зберегти ось цей
ефект несподіванки вони навіть не
попередили власні підрозділи тобто ті
підрозділи які знаходились на лівому
березі Дніпра не були попереджені в
судячи з усього і після підйому води
почали хаотично евакуйовуватись власними
силами зрозуміло що лишаючи там
колективну зброю майно на позиціях які
були затоплені і вибираючись внаслідок
цього за наявними даними оперативника
достатньо вже кількість поранених і
знищених тим більше того їм у цьому
допомагають наші збройні сили України
тому що противник який хаотично
переміщується і по воді там
напівзатопленому стані його набагато Не
легше і знищувати
звісно цинізму росіян не маєш Так звані
російські воєнкори теж доливають не води
у каховську ГЕС розповідаючи як це все
чудово що головне - це успіх тактичний а
не ті наслідки які можуть бути І що
нічого поганого ну Таких дієс немає
головне це як вони кажуть військовий
успіх а якими цілями це буде досягнуто
це вже така другорядна для них тим не
менш кардинально кардинально Я думаю що
на е подальше просування збройних сил
України це не вплине тому що знову ж
таки повторюся лівий берег Дніпра нижчий
росіяни своїми ж діями затопили свої ж
позиції там де збройні сили України мали
би вичищати Не знищувати ворога це все
зробило за нас вода